old Donna Summer [ __ ] you know like dude
I have what does that no way I think
it's nowhere to run
oh nothing right I got some playlists
thinking is what okay
Allman Brothers or James Brown like you
go you go back in time when you listen
to that you listen to James Brown song
it's not just that you're listening to
James Brown you're listening to a time
capsule from 1963 or whatever it was
he's so astonishing oh yeah James Brown
he was amazing oh like that I when I
hear Zeppelin and I hear James Brown I
never get I never lose my shock at how
good they were how unique it was yeah no
Zeppelin was incredible the only thing
that ain't Zeppelin is this I know
allegations of plagiarism which seem to
be totally true I know I've heard the
song so you can do this side by side
with Sam you stole those riffs yeah
that's rough yeah it's unfortunate
because the end result is [ __ ]
incredible
you're still so great the immigrant song
one of the best workout songs of all how
much credit today I mean should they
have that I'm not trying to disparage it
at all but like they should get a lot of
credit for how good they were still they
were still the greatest they were the
definitive they're the definitive
heavy-metal
they're so good band of all there's no
doubt that they're so good that see the
thing is it every song I don't know you
know I don't know how every band does it
every song is probably constructed
differently put in a lot of cases
there's a lot of people contributing to
the song you know the drummer has an
idea and the singer has an idea and the
guitar player has these riffs he's
trying out and they're trying to figure
out the best way to do this song it's a
collaborative effort it's no doubt that
the collaboration was [ __ ] phenomenal
the question is was it consensual like
how many of these people were
collaborating and didn't know it so
that's what happens if you're
plagiarizing
it seems like it's okay and you know
maybe they just thought that band's
gonna go away no one's gonna care about
right anymore because we're LED
[ __ ] Zeppelin that's possible
too because before the internet that
kind of would have been in the case you
know no one but now we're still are
taking something that doesn't belong to
you you definitely also in my opinion
you have to buy that from the person yes
give them credit yes
but there's no way you can discount the
fact that there were [ __ ] when
they were on top when Robert Plant would
stand on that [ __ ] stage with his
shirt open I mean he's the what's one of
the weirdest things like what the thing
about that change in history right go
from 1950 to 969 go nineteen years and
you see you go from people that look
like Hank Williams senior to Robert
Plant what apparently was wearing the
blouses or dresses or t-shirts that the
girl he had the night before had worn do
you know that doesn't it we're on stage
that's correct sir that's what I hear so
probably [ __ ] his way through his
shirt he always wore girls shirts that
were too small for him well you could
always see his hog in his pants yeah he
always has hog pressed to the side yeah
the the the every every heavy metal band
in the 80s poison you name it whatever
Motley Crue they all had a blonde lead
singer boys yeah that was because their
hero is mr. Robert yeah no he's a beast
dude they're he's wearing a girl's shirt
oh my god that's amazing
yeah that's amazing that shirt barely
fits him damn right all of so many of
those pictures what a crazy life that
guy let yes look at that you know I
don't think any one of us will ever be
able to understand even even if you
became like the new Led Zepplin you'll
never understand what it's like to be
Led Zepplin in the seventies yeah in the
70s what clique imagine if you today
became the new giganto [ __ ] multi
country rock doesn't matter too many
people watching you well it's not just
that too many people watching you and
there's a lot of you you got to think
that's when Robert Plant was Robert
Plant who are the royalty you were you
were literally like a king yeah you had
who you had Rolling Stones had Elton
John yet people yet people but maybe you
have 30 yeah you might have 30 yeah 30
big name artists maybe maybe maybe but
it's true maybe a hundred let's get
crazy hey do you have Pink Floyd you got
The Who what do you think about the
Beatles obviously CDC yeah yeah you got
all sorts of [ __ ]
you got a lot a lot going on back then
you know